so leute bevor es mit dem video losgeht
noch eine kurze ansage ich hatte leider
ein kleines technisches problem und mir
ist die facetime abgepackt deswegen
gibt's diese folge ohne face kam aber
die folge war so gut besucht gefallen
als gedacht habt die bringst du mal ihr
könnt ihr übrigens in die kommentare
schreiben ob ihr facetime unbedingt
braucht aber das wollt oder nicht ob es
euch vielleicht egal ist einfach und in
die kommentare schreiben
dann würde ich sagen viel spaß mit der
folge rohstoffen und bis gleich das herz
macht härter hey was hat er vor
ich versteh's wegspringen
los gehts und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge road to top ten
heute haben wir als gast den dennis
tucker analyst ich ja was genau wie
enthusiastisch wie irgendwie schon
einmal mächtig wird nehmen ich bin das
papier geht hat sich gewünscht die
kommentar wie immer hier
pa pa pa pa pa pa kamera kommt kamera da
kaum noch einer
natürlich sagen wir checken ob kurz-
platz 70 ohne wieder bis leicht so dass
wir in der runde
es geht los watte ober gerne lustig hey
was geht ab bremer erfreut es geht es in
den runden zu sehen und nicht ins wasser
fallen wird sagt ja ihr verhasste
twisted wusste natürlich wird ihr wissen
in der regel gar nichts sie müssen ihr
platz 70 erreichen platz 17 reichten
kommt die nächste folge ihr wisst ja
denn es ist heute im business-outfit ich
habe einen [ __ ] nur geht wobei
jetzt hab ich gar nicht gesehen was
hannes auszuwählen mann und jetzt habe
ich das trackpad checker geht wenn ihr
geht der sound auf dieser räudige schöne
switcher wirft er die mein gott zwischen
aus einer der im holz claudia der typen
meine fraser aber okay geben dass seine
zum beispiel wie er will
was hast du mal sketchen mal gespielt
recker ja klar
ja da kennst du doch den sound wenn man
einen trecker aber ohne kind vorstellen
euro in meinen augen ist im august los
ich glaube ich mich mal hinten rein
ja du roi die gerne weil er will einfach
willst du mich verarschen junge ganz
ehrlich dafür schlage dich bei der hand
das habe ich immer wieder hatten wieder
handtuch geschlagen papier jetzt ja das
ist jetzt richtig whisky sind ja richtig
was die leute
nein bitte nicht warum wohl nicht
weggehauen nach facto skelett ist halt
doch mal deine schnauze ganz wenige
kommen junge dieser typ mir war gar
nicht so recht hat mich so zum rage
gebracht
ganz ehrlich der einfach so weist der
kam so hinein hat den switches schon in
der handels- oder alt als würde mich
versüßte wesen der welt erhalten das
aber sowas nicht peilt who einer ganz
kann man sich so aufregen leute ihr
macht euch kein bild ist so lustig es
ist einfach aussehen sollen bei mir
älter aber jetzt merke jetzt können wir
hier die stadtstaaten den chip ist
unser erstes opfer wir sind voll gereckt
jetzt warum plötzlich ihr dieses kapital
ihr habt gesehen für sowas ist halt
richtig geil dieses vampir christen geht
was mir echt richtig viel spaß macht zu
spielen weil es einfach sehr sehr gut im
pvp einzusetzen ist gerade wenn ihr
mehrere gegner habt könnt ihr
unglaublichen vorteil daraus machen dass
sie einfach und das video heute bei dir
jetzt direkt krass und haben einfach im
wasser gegeben
heftige sache hätte ich niemals gedacht
das ist das geld
ich hätte niemals gedacht räumen lassen
bekennt sich aber die rüstung reinpacken
das ist übrigens ein guter trick
umrüstung sachen zu entsorgen
für dirk eine verwendung habt auch bei
den ja auch nicht wollte dass die gegner
die bekommen einfach in die ändert es
packen weil wenn die energy studies bond
verschwinden die sachen damit und das
ganz toll es erinnert mich irgendwie an
harry potter oder irgendwie an diese
magische handtasche von herrn soja auf
jeden kurze frage ich heute wieder raus
sagte bock vorher also kann ja sein dass
irgendwelche leute von mir und berlin
kommt auf fast am anschlag hatte ok
damals auf halbwegs gewählt jetzt müssen
uns bei allen nein ich hab dir einen
guten job ich bin der dümmste mensch der
welt du bist hier oben aber kommt der
king
er wusste da geben wir geben nicht
kampflos aufgeben nicht kampflos auf
mein freund wir geben nicht kampflos
orbit jetzt ich nicht ich habe keine
feinde mehr
der marsch da kann dann noch mal noch
ein anderer ja krassesten man okay leute
sind zunächst ohne wieder am kit wie
immer wir sehen uns dass wir wieder
weiter mit der zweiten runde dann
schauen wir dass wir diese runde
vielleicht nicht ins wasser gerutscht
werden weil wir waren echt gut dabei ein
superstart wirklich schade dass wir da
diese unter nicht gewonnen haben ich
würde sagen mit seinem equipment gewinnt
man neun von zehn runden
wenn man hat es ist halt immer die
maxime der finanz wasser geschwitzt wird
da kann man halt recht wenig machen das
ein bisschen kacke
genauso wenig kann man machen wenn man
keine ändern findet deswegen gucken war
dass wir die hier luton getrieben und
leute ihr habt vielleicht hat eben schon
gehört denn es hat versucht anzusprechen
aber es ging so ein bisschen in der
hektik unter wir sind dieses wochenende
wo in berlin etwas machen in berlin
richtig die video dvd ist für alle die
es nicht wissen
ein treffen an richtig richtig großes
treffen bei dem sich alle youtuber und
ganz viele minecraft der unter anderem
roth pilz re wieder treffen und zwar
diese treffen sich die leute weil sie im
netzwerk die move sind in dem ich auch
bin deswegen heißt auch die video und
ich freue mich richtig drauf wir sind ja
unterwegs mit der wahl mit mitteilt wies
mit krankhafter und den ganzen
hohmeister petric bestimmt auch da und
es wird richtig geil und ich habe
darüber sagen ich gebe euch würde jetzt
angebot machen dass ich da einfach einem
kleinen video drehte meine allererste
blog weiß nicht ob ich so etwas kann
aber ich denke da kann man jetzt nicht
so unfassbar viel falsch machen
helga bock drauf habt schaut einfach mal
die kommentare die wieder wie locker bis
lust drauf dann komme ich mich darum ob
wo ist der bewusste erst wo ist der
coolste typ
die grafik front machen dann ist er weg
jetzt ganz wichtig leute immer von
attacken haben wir ein bisschen das ist
wissen das equipment am helfen hier so
ein bisschen da oben ist und pick am
sein
es tut mir mal anheben
was wissen helfen alter des mondes
vermuten ich war so lustig als gesehen
habe das money boy einfach ja um
gespielt wieder um gefilmt video
kommentiert hat man ist so geil meinte
ja moneyball fährst du das siehst wie
fest mit einem fitten und man lieber
committee einfach das war so lustig und
jetzt irgendwann in schweden aufgenommen
oder so richtig coole leute
falls sie da mal bock drauf hab
irgendwie ich weiß nicht ich gebe ja
viele leute die sich denken so money boy
bauer finde ich überhaupt nicht lustig
dann geht es an leute die die hat seine
satire so ein bisschen verstehen
dann gibt es wieder andere die ihn
überhaupt nicht kennen aber für alle die
manchmal ein bisschen lustig finden und
vielleicht auch bald mit alimentari mit
adi art was habe ich katharina riedl die
mit den leuten was anfangen können die
kölner auf deren channels vorbei schon
der schönsten und vor gott er wurde auch
für switch ungünstig
der vogel und ich habe auch ich sehr ich
glaube ich immer auf einem bogen
ich weiß nicht wo er trifft mich
wahrscheinlich
moment ich habe einfach kein pfeil dass
hier auch mal gold erfüllen dafür sollte
nicht nur für ein leider sagt zack zack
pampa und die könnte auch die die akkus
machen
das ist auch überhaupt kein thema mit
dem totenbett gerade voll gesperrt ja
krass alter davon ist einer den können
wir uns necken gäste gilt das richtige
outfit die sachen auch die sachen auf
was er bitte also ich hab gestern also
ich bin da jan haben halt mit abonnenten
gespielt also mit sein und dann war halt
ein abonnent von mir und ihm bei
der inhalt beziehen und auf jeden fall
also wir waren beide auf den gleichen
fleck berater info wer getötet hat er
mich okay muss das problem weil es
einfach sinnlos ist also ich finde
dieses ganze ansichten und so eine
scheiße
läuteten verboten den haben wir richtig
gut gegeben leute richtig richtig gut
gegeben haben wir schön den giftschrank
in die fresse geklaute verkackt starb
und hat leider auch die bierbude auch
schon haben auf jeden fall läuft diese
runde genauso gut wie in der letzten
mindestens genau so gut wie man immer
noch keinen bogen
das ist etwas was mir ich sage das will
ich jetzt nicht so optimal ganz ehrlich
bin ich nicht zufrieden mit deswegen
lernen das emmental da lag bestimmt
irgendwo bogen um johann mein doktor
knochen hätte ich mir so war es also
eine hunde armee machen können
denn range rover range kraft alter habe
ich richtig glück gehabt er hat mit
seiner range einiges gegeben alter krass
songbeat gaming es sind auch nur noch
drei leute da oder was der friedrich
ich weiß gar irgendwie sind die ganzen
dinge so aus als wenn die entscheidet
und wir haben power mit bogen sehr geil
richtig gut richtig gut das perfekt da
können wir gleich schön die bogen jetzt
verteilt und die saison gut gamer ist
nicht so schlecht dem macht was jetzt
gerade so gesehen habt ihr im kampf
gegen ihn könnte man einiges erwarten
von dem deswegen ist es sehr gut dass
wir hier in power bogen haben nehmen da
schön die chance mit extra schaden geben
meyer
manchmal habe ich also manchmal denke
ich mir so du hast ja eigentlich noch
proben skills weil manchmal läuft es bei
mir was macht er wenn wir nicht jetzt
was jetzt was jetzt besser da
mai laufen haufen alter ja gut gemacht
gut gemacht von ihm auf jeden fall und
ich habe ich an bilanz bad fucking
potters wir springen jetzt einfach mal
hinterher
wir hoffen dass der king of rock'n der
viertbesten aber ich glaube essen haie
oder so lange unter wasser bleibt ihr
müsst eigentlich seien garantiert
garantieren was kann das kit hey hey hey
hey kann hat resistance und und
regeneration im wasser jetzt ist aber
alles im wasser hat fast unmöglich zu
kühlen
ich glaube und ich glaube das ist ein
heiß lang wieder unter wasser war
augusto kollege von regel unter der nähe
der vorne vor nässe und kälte
hey was hat dir vor ich verstehe mich
gerne an und ich verstehe nicht was der
kollege vorhat
ja ok aber was auch immer gerade fort
ich habe keine ahnung leute das zeigt
doch gerade ein bisschen
es war eine richtig geile folge die
zweite runde gewonnen es war der erste
auf einen versuch für alle die sich das
jetzt nicht haben denken können ich
würde sagen euch die folge gefallen hat
las einen daumen nach oben da schreibt
wie immer die kids in die kommentare
beim nächsten mal spielen kann janis ab
dessen der beschreibung dann sehen was
beim nächsten video wieder sind mir
richtig spaß gemacht heute natürlich
sagen haut rein macht es gut und